I'm the snow crashing very funny show
you play yourself is it hard playing
yourself as an actor no that's what I've
been doing my entire limited acting
career like real actors are like Anthony
Hopkins where he played that serial
killer and salads of the land of
electors yeah and then like the next
move that should have ended his career
like you should never been able to see
him as anybody else and then the next
movie he played like John Quincy Adams
and he was literally John Quincy Adams
my buddy saw this thing one time John
Travolta was talking about like just the
walks he's like Vinnie Barbarino walked
this way Vincent Vega and walked this
way like you know whatever the guy from
get shorty walks this way and I just met
with to hearing that going through all
my characters walk like me they all have
a Boston accent they all look like that
I just I am like I just I'm trying to be
believable yeah as yourself yeah it's
basically the the least amount of work
you could possibly do as a performer
that's what I that's very good it's
working for you yeah I think so you know
yeah
I don't know